the Joe Rogan experience when you look
at human civilization and you go back to
the origins of religion and you look
towards the future do you envision a
time where humanity is free of what you
would consider irrational belief systems
or belief systems are not based on fact
I do I'm not sure it'll come soon but I
do and I look forward to that time of
course I think we're moving in the right
direction and the figures bear that out
in even in America which is office of
the scale of Western civilization's even
in America the number of people who now
subscribe to a religion is is is
dropping dramatically and the number who
say they have no religion is now about
25% that's a lot there is a deal and
that compares to any one particular
Christian denomination and yet
politically that group the the nuns the
note the no beliefs have no Lobby they
have no no powerful pressure group so
politicians will go out there and suck
up to I don't know the Irish Lobby the
Polish lot lobby the Jewish lobby the
Catholic Lobby etc but the atheist lobby
hasn't got his act together or isn't
only just now beginning to get his act
together well politically I think people
are terrified of the concept because
it's such a such a long branch to go out
on one of the things he brought up in
The God Delusion was the willingness of
people to vote for a gay candidate for
president a black candidate for
president a woman candidate for
president but then an atheist which is
what I believe 40% they think they think
that you've got to have a belief in some
kind of higher power in order to be
moral but the weird thing is that it
doesn't have to be the same higher power
as the one you believe it anyone will do
right as long as they as long as there
is one but if you don't believe in a
higher power you must be immoral you and
that of is totally ridiculous when you
think about the horrible immorality of
for example the both the Bible and the
Koran
which are horrific in the sense that if
you Billy if you actually got your
morals if you got your moral values from
the Old Testament or the Quran and they
they share that great deal of course you
would be strolling adult roses to death
and sterling people to death for
breaking the Sabbath and doing he
sacrifices human sacrifices and animal
sacrifices all sorts of horrible things
which of course do go on now
in Islamic countries especially gay
people getting thrown off high buildings
and women being beheaded for the crime
of being seen with a man not their
husband and that kind of thing so that
that we could see what you get when you
get your morality from an Abrahamic
scripture and yet there are still people
in this country who say you cannot be
moral unless you believe in a higher
power what do you think let's extract
these this concept of a higher power
let's let's get rid of it let's let's
get rid of where where do you think
people get their morals and their ethics
from and that's a profoundly difficult
question we clearly don't get them from
religion and yet we get them from
somewhere and you can demonstrate that
by the fact that the moral values of any
particular century are markedly
different from those of other centuries
even decades so in the 21st century we
here now have moral values which are
really significantly different from a
hundred years ago or two hundred years
ago or three hundred years ago and
within any one of those centuries you
could take people who are in the
vanguard of moral progress for example
in the 19th century Abraham Lincoln
Charles Darwin th Huxley would have been
on the liberal progressive end of the
spectrum and other people to be on the
opposite end but even Abraham Lincoln
for example made a speech quoted in
outgrowing God in which he said of
course no nobody would seriously think
that black people are the
of white people nobody would seriously
say that black people should be allowed
to vote or should be allowed to marry
white people this is Abraham Lincoln who
freed the slaves right and was as I say
in the forefront of progressive thought
Charles Darwin again was in favor of
freeing the slaves he was passionately
anti-slavery but he too thought that
there was no question about black people
being the equal of white people they
obviously weren't and-and-and and Huxley
Thomas Huxley again Darwin's Bulldog
thought the same way now those people
were at the forefront as I say today
they would still be in the forefront and
they would be horrified to look back on
what they said mmm
in the 19th century well something is
changing as the centuries go by I in art
growing god I call it something in the
air which of course doesn't explain
anything but what I mean by that is that
it's not literally hovering in the air
but it's a concur it's a [ __ ] collection
of all conversations between people
dinner party conversations parliamentary
decisions congressional debates judicial
decisions by judges juries newspaper
articles journalism all these things
together conspire together to produce
something in the air something that that
defines a given century or maybe even a
given decade with the moral values of
that of that decade then the knowledge
base which is just so superior today in
in terms of what the general public has
access to in terms of what we understand
about human beings it's just different
than it was back then and it continues
to be different and now with the
internet we have so much more access to
these conversations and it's not just
about being a dinner table with the
right people you can watch YouTube
videos yourself debating religious
scholars or so that so the that progress
of something in the air has
as it were take on an accelerated pace
because of the internet yeah and I think
that's a very hopeful sign of course the
Internet also can be used for the
opposite purpose but there I think
there's a kind of asymmetry there
because especially if you look at United
areas of the world like Afghanistan and
Pakistan where until recently the idea
of being an atheist was simply
inconceivable it was off the radar
they didn't even consider it it wasn't
something that they thought was possible
now they do because they got the
internet and we've got a project within
CFI of downloading free of charge as
PDFs several of my books including The
God Delusion and we'll be outgrowing God
as well and these are being downloaded
by large numbers of people
the first PDF download of the Arabic
edition of The God Delusion was
downloaded 13 million times
Arabic Edition 13 million times so now
they are being exposed to the
possibility of atheism which wasn't a
posit
of course they're still being the
Internet is also exposing them to
Islamic propaganda but they've had that
all along from Imams mullahs and and
their madrasah schools but now they've
got that you've got it coming the other
way as well and I have great hope that
the internet will mark a turning point
[Applause]